what's going on
regeneration I'm Greg Alva the grand
gala I'm Tara Erickson for me Tara
Erickson from the Tara Harrison channel
on YouTube go check her out for some
really fun content over there
also followed her on social media all
links in the description box
hey Sarah yeah I'd be ever in the ball
before yeah every day of my life
dodgeball is back and Ben Stiller wants
you to join I love Ben special charity
event I like that these charities do
these fake sequels movies yeah there is
the Red Nose Day actually one another's
dodgeball is back whatever this is the
dodgeball that's one of those comedies
and when I saw the trailer I'm like this
looks so stupid and then I watch it
every night I watch I think it's just a
funny nobody makes me beat my own blood
lol and over here I feel like me team
blaze laser blazer plane blazer brother
Jack I'm excited for CrossFit before
paleo before school cycle there was only
one name in citrus
hello losers miss me sorry director
internet life but for the last 13 years
while I've been living a sugar-free
cooking forward life now I've watched as
all of you have gotten fatter and done
with your hashtags your phase near
Kanye's everyone is so classy now even
good old-fashioned bullying is out well
white Goodman has decided to get with
the times that's right it's time for a
little charity dodgeball [ __ ] those
two critters animées have decided to
offer you mouth-breathers an amazing
chance to win a once-in-a-lifetime
experience played a little dodgeball
with me white Goodman you heard me
what have you looking losers and
probably only friends can come test your
dodge ball middle against the best ball
in the biz c1 really not so fast white
[Music]
long time pal see you're sticking with
the hare choice strong move yes I am
sticking with a hair choice oh you okay
I just threw up in my mouth a little huh
anyhow sorry to interrupt your super
weird thing here but we figured we
should jump in we want to get everyone
out there a choice
you talk to camera okay haha okay if you
don't talk to anything you can enter for
a chance to play on logo gems teams on
our team average joe's take you
forgotten it takes two teams to play
dodgeball White City don't you to return
movers you want two teams you got it
Jackie both Tobi's purple other bracket
Oh God you remember my biggest concern
Gary Michelle and what's the most
edgiest legally female lady dodgeballer
plan southern maskavich
[Music]
huh you want to do this again why we'll
do this again and we'll whip your ass
just like we did last night
Oh nobody rips my ass except me and
sometimes mission huh please would you
please follow me baby goes to sleep on
the ground because he got hit in the
face with a wrench white I'm gonna drop
you like third period French it's on oh
yeah it's on it's on PS it's on so much
that it never was fall like it was a
waste of energy because he kept it on ha
ha
prepare to be humiliated on aging and
television for charity pump the brakes
white this long is bigger than window
for us
[Music]
good Renee's comm SATs grilled opah Joey
Nike Pro - amazed outcomes last chose to
join our team don't go to the Mesa on
the sash nothing you don't you don't you
know you don't last jobs no that's just
don't ever joke vs. purple culprit come
to the charity speak to the ball oh cool
ah so awesome I wonder if they did that
already
I don't know I'd be pretty amazed that
would be so cool to play dodge ball
still our Ben Stiller and Vince long and
some people they didn't get in character
the whole time I think Vince Vaughn is
just a giant and I would be like I don't
know how to respond now he's like six
six kind of will have you over the years
he has he's gotten a little a little bit
heavy
yeah not too bad though he still cute oh
yeah long sweater covers that man had a
long floor then Stiller though I think
he was saying character the whole time
I was delivered and seeing that I was
watching it I was like is he gonna talk
being character the whole time we're
playing Oswell or is he gonna switch
back from like Ben yeah and Cobra mattis
when I was watching this it kind of made
me think like since so many years since
either that have been in a really good
comedy the last time they did cousin
Rivers at times they were bold like they
were hot they were a hot comedy they
were they were the they were the people
hiring and fun they were like the big
ones
wolf Farrell still has like he has a hit
every once in a while yeah yeah they've
kind of Lee died off a little bit yeah I
mean I'd like lastly comedies as fun as
that is nothing very good or made money
because they're not very good films Ben
Stiller does like Night at the Museum or
something right but I really Vince
Vaughn was in oh he wasn't it wasn't as
serious with Tarantino's know your the
hacks are rich he was yeah he's a
hacksaw that was a great movie it isn't
sure detective season 2 you remember I
saw we're just so good oh my god yes you
wasn't that
and serious wrong acknowledge these guys
could come back with like a funny
Boulder in Zoolander with this one like
Zoolander you look terrible dude I
didn't you - yeah that was tears you
Leonard the first one no sir
it's great yeah I mean I miss what
happened to these guys I miss them you
know because they were part of the like
vulgar pg-13 comedies yeah Godfather's
like have sexual content and perverted
jokes and then Judd Apatow came around
and started introducing like r-rated you
know people bantering kind of right you
know bro comedy Deanna and I feel like
they sort of faded out and they never
really had tapped in Vince Vaughn
because mental entire wedding crashers
but after that he never really tapped
into a good r-rated comedy either has
been still or even helping doesn't even
attempted to go into like a good r-rated
comedy mm-hmm and I don't know I like
them to come have you just do it I'll
get you a job your job man man that'd be
awesome yeah start to see you know how
have you seen that no oh it's so funny
man yeah I need to watch these two and
Elwood Wilson and oh man I feel most
hysterical then Vince come on you two G
made a comeback thing seriously I mean
in a positive way a lot bad people I
know I grew up Catholic it's hilarious
oh really be attracted to Jewish girls
cuz they were like really exotic to me
oh they are they are kind of exotic you
don't believe in Jesus I do I do but
let's not make babies but let's walk on
the fire baby right that's a yeah that's
what I would saying I put it here in
here yeah I'm gonna check out this
amazing because because he wants the
Jews to come back he's it not my words
he said overall the Jews go
Oh God you're still around there's a lot
around and you know what the Jewish guys
they really know how to take a lady on a
date yeah they do they have their [ __ ]
together they're not just gonna be like
take you out on a date and be like hey
you pay for like half of it I'll always
put my car down I always say prep
because it's decent I went on two dates
Jewish guys they were like no just know
that you're never when you come out with
me like links for the first few like I'm
gonna take care of you know man
cool and they opened doors yeah that's
why I don't do that
I didn't even get an A come out with me
and you pay for yourself you're an
independent woman we live in a feminist
world now you get your own [ __ ] Mandy
should be paying for me why are we
serving my card out but I love it when
else no no my cool uh yeah that's what
you got your everyday car not that I'm
supposed to go yeah you need to court me
it's on me come pick me up take me out
open my doors and the next day we'll
split the check horrid sorry simple
first one just like get your [ __ ]
together this has been a lesson in
dating listen I want the Jews to come
back baby
these are still round it never to God
said the rhodium Jewish I think Wonder
Woman's yours
well she's our Israel I don't know if
she's Jewish
I'm still from Israel or Jewish right
kind of the DNA that's Jewish blood
I don't she's a practising gear Judaism
I look Jewish I'm curly hair subscribe
button they exist
click notification metals leo to be big
terror Erickson's of terror Erickson
channel that's right I am
you can find me at Karason on instagram
as we'll add these here Arizona and
Twitter and like care Erickson on
YouTube planet first
should we cut yeah yeah